TONIGHT.
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IN CASE YOU WEREN'T INVITED, THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS
DINNER TOOK PLACE OVER THE
WEEKEND.
FOR THE THIRD YEAR IN A ROW,
DONALD TRUMP WAS INVITED BUT
TOOK A PASS AND DIDN'T SHOW UP.
THAT HAS NEVER HAPPENED IN THE
LONG HISTORY OF THE DINNER.
PRESIDENTS ALWAYS SHOW UP IN A
TUXEDO AND HEAD DOWNTOWN TO SUCK
UP TO THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS ASSOCIATION.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
THEY HATE GOING.
EVERY ONE OF THEM.
THEY ALL DEEPLY DESPISED THE
NEWS MEDIA, BUT THEY MAKE THE
CHOICE.
IT IS A HOSTAGE SITUATION.
THE PRESS WILL PUNISH YOU,
GUARANTEED.
THEY WON'T ADMIT IT.
THEY WILL MAKE UP SOME STORY.
HERE FOR EXAMPLE IS JEFF
ZUCKER'S SPOKESMAN, CLAIMING
THAT NOT GOING TO MEDIA DINNER
IS THE SAME AS ATTACKING THE
MEDIA.
>> SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT THE
PRESS.
THIS HASN'T BEEN SINCE OUR FIRST
AMENDMENT.
>> YES, AN AWARDS DINNER AND A
FUND-RAISER APPEARED IN THE
PAST, PRESIDENTS HAVE ALWAYS
SHOWED UP.
IT IS YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
WHAT WE ARE SEEING.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S ATTACK
AGAINST THE MEDIA TAKES MANY
FORMS.
THE PRESIDENT HAVING A RALLY
THIS SATURDAY INSTEAD OF
ATTENDING THE DINNER.
>> Tucker: SOME PEOPLE ARE SO
SELF-CONFIDENT.
HAVE YOU NOTICED THAT?
ALMOST LIKE THERE IS A
SELF-ESTEEM CONFIDENCE REVERSE
ACCESS.
THEY ARE TELLING US THAT GOING
TO YOUR OWN EVENTS INSTEAD OF
HOURS IS A FORM OF HARASSMENT.
YOU KNOW WHY IT'S NOT, ACCORDING
TO CNN?
SPYING ON JAMES ROSEN AND HIS
PARENTS BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE
WHAT HE'S COVERING.
THEN OBAMA WENT TO A SEPARATE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS
ASSOCIATION DINNERS.
NOBODY EVER DENOUNCED HIM.
OBAMA HATED REPORTERS, BY THE
WAY.
MOST PEOPLE DO, WITH GOOD
REASON.
BUT THEY LEFT HIM BACK ANYWAY.
THEY AGREED WITH HIS POLITICS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY
DON'T.
>> I STILL SEPARATED MY CAREER.
BEFORE 2017 AND WHAT CAME
AFTERWARDS.
THAT IS WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES CALLED US THE
ENEMIES OF THE PEOPLE.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS TIME THAT WE
RESET THIS, PUT IT A LITTLE BIT
MORE SQUARELY ON JOURNALISM AND
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
A LITTLE BIT MORE ON THE PEOPLE,
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO HELPED TO
HOLD THE MOST POWERFUL
INSTITUTION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
NOW I AM DELIGHTED TONIGHT FOR
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
WE NOW HAVE TO FIGHT HARD FOR
BASIC TRUTHS WE ONCE TOOK FOR
GRANTED.
LIKE EVERY FUTURE PRESIDENT,
WASHINGTON FELT MALIGNED AND
MISUNDERSTOOD BY THE PRESS.
BUT HE NEVER GENERALIZE THAT
INTO A VENDETTA AGAINST THE
INSTITUTION.
I THINK YOU ARE DOING NOBLE WORK
TO PRESERVE DEMOCRACY DURING A
TIME WHEN A RISING TIDE OF
MISINFORMATION THREATENS TO MAKE
A MOCKERY OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT THE FIRST
AND WON'T BE THE LAST AMERICAN
PRESIDENT TO CREATE JITTERS
ABOUT THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
BUT WHAT IS HAPPENING TODAY IS
PERHAPS EVEN MORE INSIDIOUS.
OUR RELENTLESS CAMPAIGN AGAINST
THE VERY CREDIBILITY OF THE NEWS
MEDIA.
>> THIS IS A GLORIOUS EDITION.
YOU FOLKS ARE A PART OF IT, AND
WE CAN'T HAVE POLITICIANS
TRAMPLING ON IT WITH IMPUNITY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: PEOPLE ARE DOUBTING
THE NEWS MEDIA.
THAT'S WRONG.
WE ARE SEEING MISINFORMATION
MASQUERADING AS NEWS, THEY ARE
TELLING US.
THEY ARE RIGHT.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF THAT
RECENTLY.
HOW ABOUT THE LAST TWO YEARS OF
RUSSIA COVERAGE?
MICHAEL COHEN MET SECRETLY.
HE IS ABOUT TO BE INDICTED.
TOLD US ALL OF THAT.
IT TOTALLY DISHONEST.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ONE MY
PULITZERS FOR WHAT TURNED OUT TO
BE MISINFORMATION MASQUERADING
AS NEWS.
LAST SATURDAY NIGHT WOULD HAVE
BEEN A PERFECT MOMENT, ACTUALLY,
TO APOLOGIZE AND RETURN THE
PRIZES THEY WON, BUT NO.
NOBODY RETURNS A PULITZER.
INSTEAD, THEY CELEBRATED
THEMSELVES.
NO SURPRISE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
WHAT WAS ODD WAS HEARING THEM
TALK ABOUT FREE SPEECH.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS IN FACT
UNDER FEROCIOUS ATTACK, MORE
THAN IN THE FIRST 50 YEARS, AND
YET THE PEOPLE IN THAT ROOM
DON'T SEEM TO NOTICE.
WHERE WERE THESE SAME PEOPLE
LAST SUMMER WHEN THE BIG TECH
COMPANIES COLLUDED TO SILENCE
ALEX JONES?
HE IS BAD.
CNN LITERALLY LEAD THE EFFORT TO
MAKE CAN BE QUIET.
JEFF ZUCKER DOESN'T AGREE WITH
HIS POLITICAL VIEWS, THEREFORE
HE THINKS HE SHOULDN'T BE
ALLOWED TO TALK.
SO ZUCKER SHUT HIM UP BY FORCE.
DID ANYONE MENTION ANY OF THAT?
AND WHERE WERE THEY WHEN
FACEBOOK AND TWITTER BLOG DADS
SUPPORTING CONGRESSWOMAN MARSHA
BLACKBURN BECAUSE THEY
CRITICIZED ABORTION?
WHERE WERE THEY WHEN HE WENT TO
PRISON IN THE U.K. FOR HAVING
UNFASHIONABLE THESE ABOUT
IMMIGRATION?
WHERE WERE THEY WHEN JAMES GOT
FIRED AND THEN SLANDERED BY
GOOGLE FOR QUESTIONING THE
COMPANY'S DIVERSITY THEOLOGY?
WHERE WERE THEY WHEN PETER LOST
HIS JOB TEACHING IN VIRGINIA
BECAUSE HE WOULDN'T USE MALE
PRONOUNS TO DESCRIBE FEMALE
STUDENTS?
DID ANY OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT
DEFENDERS -- HERE THEY ARE, DID
THEY SAY A SINGLE WORD ABOUT ANY
OF THIS?
OF COURSE THEY DIDN'T.
THEIR JOB, THEY SAY, IS TO HOLD
THE POWERFUL TO ACCOUNT, BUT
WHEN GIVEN THE CHANCE TO PUSH
BACK AGAINST THE TRULY ACTUALLY
POWERFUL, WE ARE NOT EVEN
KIDDING -- GOOGLE, AMAZON,
FACEBOOK, PAYPAL -- DO THEY SAY
ANYTHING EVER?
NO.
OF COURSE NOT.
THEY SUCK UP.
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
THEY SUCK UP TO POWER.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHO THEY ARE.
BEAUTIFUL TOADIES TO THE